les voyages forment la jeunesse et ce ne
sont pas les collégiens de la montagne
qui vont dire le contraire une classe de
4e de cet établissement s'est envolé
pour la bretagne région à l'origine du
peuplement de la réunion les enfants
excités des parents un peu stressé
l'ambiance était un peu spéciale à
quelques heures du départ
reste à voir
peut-être oui beaucoup
oui est ce que tu es content de prendre
l'avion
sont en bretagne mais la laisser passer
est ce que comme dit elle est toujours
intéressant faciale filles en plus
figure mais bon mais au moins c'est une
bonne chose qu elle et les découpes
d'autres choses elle découvre pas que la
réunion ait des comptes d'autres pays
serait bien paul parmi les familles une
grand mère bretonne venue accompagner sa
petite fille pour le grand voyage témoin
jamais été à bresse ain draham
responsabilité elle va à lorient moi
jamais tu es toi tu es contente d'aller
visiter le pays de ta grand mère oui
parce qu'elle t'a parlé un petit peu de
la bretagne oui et c'est peut-être là
que la peau tannée se ferait
et tu as hâte de découvrir ça
au programme de ce séjour la bretagne
mais plus spécialement la culture
bretonne et une belle rencontre avec les
petits bretons du collège diwan qui
présente la particularité de faire un
enseignement en langue bretonne un
échange d'une journée qui a permis à
chacun d'appréhender la culture de
l'autre une journée qui a débuté par une
présentation de chaque région fait que
vous avez entendu ce cas particulier
dans ce collège wen un bourreau voilà
alors le breton c'est quoi là vous avez
cette carte là vous la connaissez c'est
quoi
c'est l'europe longtemps en europe il ya
des gens qui sont arrivés de parla de
l'est on sait pas trop d'où qui sont
arrivés ont peuplé tout europe on les
appelle les cents le collège diwan
classé parmi les meilleurs collèges de
france a fait le choix d'un enseignement
différent qui porte ses fruits et qui
permet aujourd'hui aux élèves d'avoir
une réelle facilité dans l'apprentissage
des autres langues évaluation l'entrée
en sixième qui a eu lieu pendant
longtemps et donc les filières bilingues
donc nous y compris on avait les
meilleurs résultats à l'évaluation à
l'entrée en 6ème de l'académie de rennes
qui est quand même la meilleure académie
de france au niveau des résultats
scolaires différents ateliers ont permis
au petit réunionnais de découvrir les
traditions de la région il faut en fait
un mélange d ici avec
ltd qui arrive et si tu gagnes aussi eh
ben tu gagnes beaucoup de poids
je ne sais pas je
n'ai pas les mots bretons des jeux mais
également un atelier de danse qui a
permis ensuite de construire une belle
farandole dans la cour du collège
de la musique réunionnaise a ponctué ce
moment d'échangé et les notes de basse
terre et du maloya venus de l'île de la
réunion ont permis de clôturer une
journée riche en émotions